le front front séduit plus que jamais la
femme française et bien sûr de l'homme
il continue de troubler l'âme comme
disait joliment la chanson une étude
chiffrée tout ce qu'il ya de sérieux
démontre que les achats de lingerie de
luxe grimpe en flèche en ce moment un
phénomène de société se cacherait qu'il
ait de soucis j'ose dire je lis sujet d'
enquête pour véronique bonnet il ya dix
ans on dormait en tee shirt et en jeter
sans soutien gorge aux orties
aujourd'hui on craque bêtement pour ces
petites choses que portait autrefois nos
grands mères les plus délurés et qui
valent souvent des fortunes ont c'est 30
% d'une population féminine mais qui
responsables de 60% des achats quelles
sont les raisons de cet engouement pour
la dentelle et la soie c'est ce que le
centre de communication avancée
détermine dans une étude sur le
comportement des françaises s'est porté
par une sorte de courant social
actuellement on pourrait appeler plaisir
quand même il ya trois bonnes raisons je
crois de croire à cette tendance la
première c'est face à la crise
un moment où on sait pas trop où on va
il faut faire des restrictions
économiques
lisa sur certains postes consommation
l'envi de profiter de la vie il a envie
de se faire plaisir quand même et de
garder des petits luxes qui ne sont pas
très cher en soi mais qui sont un
symbole qu'on n'est pas dans une société
de pénurie et à une deuxième chose qui
est pour que je crois pour la lingerie
c'est que à une époque où de plus en
plus de femmes travaillent adopte au
fond des métiers des comportements et
des costumes d'hommes il doit le besoin
derrière cette façade un peu
masculiniser de se sentir quand même
femme et je dirais derrière le costume
d'homme de garder un peu les dessous
féminins pour être toujours prêt à
séduire au cas où
car d'abord d'avoir un pilote un soir on
peut plus porter autre chose
c'est doux c'est pour ce sens différente
les hommes ont des goûts très précis
depuis quelques années ils savent eux il
ne se trompe jamais sur les tailles de
leurs compagnes ils savent exactement le
tour de poitrine le tour de taille le
tour de hanches et même la pointure pour
les bas et ils ont des goûts enfin c'est
eux qui me font avancer aussi parce que
j'ai eus j'attache beaucoup d'importance
à la lance du niger des modèles
absolument
et ce qui est très drôle très souvent
nous avons des cadeaux de rupture aussi
les hommes qui viennent tout seuls qui
choisissent à une culotte et soutien
gorge un porte jarretelles et des bas
ils ne font et nous demande d'aller
livrer une personne avec un petit mot
comme cadeau de rupture
jusque dans les modalités de la rupture
usage d'une lingerie très connoté
annonce à coup sûr le retour à la
théâtralité on peut se demander si ce
recours à la mise en scène du corps est
le signe d'une séduction plus élaboré et
plus inventives au contraire
profondément puritaine car on le sait
l'artifice est le meilleur moyen de se
dérober se cacher derrière des 2sous
fait pour être montrée peut-être
l'assurance des fantasmes les plus
balisée
[Musique]